jean-louis borloo est l'invité de
preuves par 3 à quelques heures du
sommet social de l'elysée bonsoir jean
louis borloo pour soi merci d'être avec
nous vous cultivez votre différence en
proclamant que l'élection présidentielle
n'a pas l'importance qu'on lui donne
cette réflexion vous est elle venue
après avoir déclaré forfait et quels
sont vos nouvelles ambitions comme
président du parti radical 1 pour ne pas
être marginalisés à ce type de questions
vous répondrai dans un instant à samir
tounsi de la fp perrine tarneaud de
public sénat lui succèdera ensuite pour
des questions plus personnelles vous
verrez d'abord jean louis borloo le chef
de l'état a formé des voeux ce mardi
pour le monde agricole dans l'ariège il
a dénoncé les règles environnementales
tatillonne qui empoisonnent les
agriculteurs est ce que le l'artisan le
maître d'oeuvre du grenelle de
l'environnement est d'accord c'était
pour lesquelles une partie de ses
phrases à l'emporte-pièce le pacte
agricole
il est forcément environnementale
d'ailleurs l'univers qui a le plus
progressé
c'est l'univers agricole les énergies
renouvelables la plus grande progression
c'est dans le monde agricole
le gaz
l'utilisation du gaz c'est dans le monde
agricole
le biogaz est manifestement le chef de
l'état n'a pas les mêmes retour que vous
tombez quand même temps des l'évolution
sur le phytosanitaire
c'est le monde agricole 40 de substances
dangereuses sont été supprimés
la croissance du bio la plus importante
d'europe 7 en france l'évolution chaque
jour de vin exploitation qui vont vers
des circuits courts c'est grâce au monde
agricole
c'est grâce aux gains mais il peut y
avoir des règles qui ne sont pas
environnementale en chef de l'état il
peut il peut être approximatif
ça peut arriver alors approximatif est
arrivé formules à l'emporté pièce
commence bien oui mais beaucoup te on
est dans un monde d'adultes bon le
président a voulu le grenelle le
grenelle agricole a été décisif le monde
agricole c'est que son avenir
il est évidemment dans la production en
circuit court avec moins de
phytosanitaires avec moins de rejet en
ayant des nouvelles ressources grâce au
niveau énergétique ghoulam vous ne
redoutez pas aujourd'hui de nouvelles
mesures nicolas sarkozy les annonces
pour relâcher la pression on se dit il
va y avoir un détricotage du grenelle
mais non mais ira pas citez moi une
mesure qui sera détricoter pas une pas
une
parce que contrairement à ce que croient
les problèmes tatillon parce que les
agriculteurs ont des sujets tatillon ils
proviennent de règles que le ministère
de l'agriculture français a accepté et a
concédé à l'europe il ya dix ans c'est
ça le problème c'est pas un problème du
grenelle de l'environnement alors
l'agriculture française c'est une
mutation absolument remarquable il faut
lui en donner acte
tout n'est pas parfait tout n'est pas
parfait mais très franchement l'idée
qu'on opposerait l'industrie à
l'environnement l'agriculture à
l'environnement les transports à
l'environnement est une conception
totalement suranné de nos propres enjeux
très bien voilà pour le chef de l'état
qui par ailleurs chef de l'état a voulu
le grenelle environ
on se souvient qu'en mai motivé vous
l'aviez noter quand même ce ça commence
à bien faire qu'il avait lancée au salon
de l'agriculture au ciné sûr j'ai même
règle tête un qui sort mettant dès
qu'ils sont des règles que il ya dix ans
messieurs l'agriculture française a
conseillé à la commission européenne
cette de vieille règle dans tous les
airs devant le chef de l'état s'est
également adressé aux chasseurs il a
pris leur parti contre le conseil d'état
qui avait été saisi par les
organisations de protection de la nature
sur la date d'ouverture de la chasse
notamment aux oies cendrées c'est bien
ça jean louis borloo est-ce qu'il a
raison de leur donner raison et s est
pas je connais trop je connais pas le
sujet moi je sais que pendant trois ans
et pour la première fois de l'histoire
de la république
il n'y avait pas de contentieux sur les
dates de chasse alliot marie avait une
table ronde
tout le monde râle et les exprimer de
chaque bord à l'est mais finalement le
gros des troupes se mettaient d'accord
sur des dates de chasse je constate
qu'il ya contentieux que j'ignorais
avant de venir ici
ouais je connais pas le sujet je ferai
donc ok comment propos d'accord alors
une agence standard and poor's a donc
dégradé la note de la france était en
fin de semaine dernière moody's nous
laisse sous surveillance et ce n'est en
moins selon vous on vous a pas encore
entendu on a beaucoup entendu les
socialistes sur le sujet est selon vous
une sanction de la politique menée en
france oui ou non vous pensez que si on
a suivi comme ça on répond vous
répondrais oui on en a mais comme je
suis pour garde à vue je vais vous
répondre
point numéro un stand and poor s'ils
sont très gentiment face et de type en
france
ça va alors pour juger pour juger de
l'avenir de notre modèle économique et
social ça me paraît un peu court
une fois que j'ai dit ça non mais parce
que c'est très important ce que moi je
veux dire monsieur moi je travaille un
dossier de mise en cause judiciaire des
agences de notation pour les erreurs
gigantesques qu'elles ont fait quand
elles nous ont dit qu'un certain nombre
de paquets de ce prime
à l'époque étaient 3 ah oui c'est vrai
qu'elle a vu à l'époque elle vous êtes
engagés dans un combat judiciaire
personne savez je suis un vieil avocat
on put moi je veux dire pourquoi c'est
très grave
c'est très grave parce que en 2008 le
monde a fait sombrer c'est la seule
activité qui peut se permettre de se
tromper à ce point sans aucune
responsabilité et c'est pourquoi il n'y
a pas de responsabilité parce qu'il est
noir américaines qui les protège
en considérant qu'ils ne font qu émettre
une opinion ses terres loi de la presse
mais pas en france pas en france et donc
j'ai décidé je suis pas membre du
gouvernement ça n'engage pas mon pays
j'ai décidé de déposer ce dossier
maintenant c'est la réalité on précise
des tribunaux français auprès des
tribunaux puisque la loi sur la presse
ne s'applique pas aux amériques qu'est
ce que vous voulez au bout du bout à
l'intention la direction les dommages
intérêts pour les dégradations qu'elles
ont produit l on prend des années
garantie garantie que tous faits y
compris lehman brothers je rappelle à
huit semaines
huit semaines du crash 3 à triple à
allez-y investissez dans mais c'est
invraisemblable c'est la rue on se
souvient de les mettre ailleurs
c'est invraisemblable ont complètement
plantés aujourd'hui des dommages et
intérêts je pense que ceux qui ont subi
des dommages doivent avoir de majorité
des dommages il ya une milliards dont il
ya un vieux principes du code civil qui
est l'article 382 qui est dit que tout
fait qui a causé à autrui un préjudice
oblige celui par la faute duquel il est
arrivé à le réparer
je demande qu'il ya un expert
international qui soit nommé pour
regarder maintenant sur le fond par
ailleurs apprenez c'est intéressant oui
mais on n'est fait mais pareil bonne
chance oui mais baissent cependant le
temps réel aux victimes
bien entendu donc venez venez signer
parce que comme on peut pas faire de
class action tout à fait ça va être
compliqué mais peu importe c'est moi
l'espère vernon mais non mais cela dit
par ailleurs
par ailleurs on est dans une situation
très difficile moi je veux pas casser le
thermomètre bon moody's a dit que trois
âmes mais ça c'est pas le sujet le sujet
il est assez clair
1 le modèle occidental le modèle
occidental en gros consomme 60 % des
ressources du monde et en produit 40
l'écart il est financé par du déficit et
donc des systèmes spéculatifs donc je
demande depuis des mois et des mois j'ai
écrit un livre n'est engagé l'allusion
juillet juillet sur dans la chambre
absolument
dans laquelle je demande pour la france
qu'il y ait une maîtrise des comptes
publics de l'ordre de 50 milliards le
gouvernement en avait fait un peu plus
de 20 je demande à l'époque on m'a ri au
nez
la taxe sur les transactions financières
je rappelle que le ministre du budget le
ministre des finances se prémunissent on
dit que ce n'était pas d'actualité et
c'était pas raisonnable par le cégep le
fond les vautours j'attende dans le
thème a pas trop car je pense qu'il faut
par ailleurs supprimer ce qu'on appelle
la niche copé faire l'exonération totale
des plus values des filiales de holdings
et enfin ce qu'on appelle les élever au
ski fait 25 milliards si on l'avait fait
j'avais déposé le texte
il ya deux mois sans parlementaire le
signer je pense qu'on n'en serait pas
dans ce bal à 20,80 borloo on connaît
donc vos propositions par ailleurs sur
le sommet social qui se transforme on
l'a bien vu enfin sommet de crise et
aujourd'hui ce qui est en cause c'est le
sait la rigidité du travail en france
c'est aussi le coût du travail et c'est
comme ça que les choses sont apparemment
présenter et c'est là que les mesures
sur les moins consensuel est ce que vous
êtes favorable à la tva sociale
alors vous dire deux mots sur l'emploi
parce que j'étais l'homme que jacques
chirac est allé chercher en 2005 quand
on n'avait pas dépassé les 10% de
chômeurs et vous souvenez peut-être
c'était de la faute du plombier polonais
10 2%
c'est quoi le chômage c'est quoi ces des
ressources humaines c'est la gestion des
ressources humaines de notre pays on se
trompe quand on croit que le cheval
c'est le sol de ce qui va pas non non
non non non non non non non non non
statistiquement cher monsieur gossio la
probabilité que le besoin de
l'entreprise x soient satisfaites par
pôle
à moins de 10 kilomètres exactement
disponibles et bien formée elle est
assez faible si vous n'avez pas une
gestion précise des ressources humaines
c'est à dire accueillir les demandeurs
d'emploi toutes les semaines
pas tous les ans toutes les semaines
alors faire un panorama des besoins
d'emploi c'est ce qu'on a vu leurs
effectifs de pôle emploi
laissez-moi peuvent plus maintenant
reste à voir les chômeurs ne serait ce
qu'une fois par mois je voudrais le
déroulé quand je suis arrivé à l'époque
c'était une fois par an on était passé
une fois par mois une fois par semaine
mais ça suffit pas d'accord il faut en
même temps où présentement dans l'emploi
les perspectives du bassin il faut que
les formateurs la formation
professionnelle soient présentes
donc moi j'ai indiquées dans ce sommet
que la priorité des priorités
c'était renforcer les capacités de pôle
emploi pour pouvoir ressort cette
richesse de la nation qui est le domaine
d'emploi de recevoir toutes les semaines
avec les égards qui lui sont dues
l'informer sur les besoins que les
moyens de la formation professionnelle
soient considérablement étendu que
partenaires sociaux chambre de commerce
chambre de métiers région état soit
autour de la table à partir de mercredi
pour qu'il ya un plan de formation
professionnelle et de qualification des
demandeurs d'emploi s'est passé il faut
de l'argent
il faut de l'argent trop de l'argent
vous n'avez pas répondre aux questions
par oui ou par non mais je me repose à
nouveau sûr j'étais bien j'y viens mais
je j'y viens pour faire ça il faut de
l'argent
donc il faudra une ressource stévia
autre chose troisièmement tendent et
troisièmement parce qu'ils adressent un
peu un petit peu les français vous avez
qu un des problèmes pour l'emploi c'est
le logement que l'accès à l'emploi se
fait sur de l'aprica garanties locatives
universelle a très bien pourquoi non
mais que les français comprennent
diarrhée il y aura plus de caution
individuel il y aura un système de
garantie universelle avec un tiers de
confiance qui vérifie que les gens sont
de bonne foi
vous savez combien ça demain matin
libère de logements en france un million
il ya un mais à deux millions deux cent
mille
inoccupée il y en a 1 millions qu'on
récupère instantanément fait du coup les
précaires vont pouvoir en bénéficier il
faut par ailleurs un plan de
qualification des adultes qui ont un
problème d'écriture et de lecture du
français il y en a près de 3 millions
avec les accès fondamentaux informatique
bureautique etc
donc c'est ensemble que j'ai je les dis
résidents partenariat tout le monde sait
public
on a besoin de ressources alors est ce
que c'est la tva est ce que c'est moi ma
thèse c'est que c'est la niche copé
d'accord niche copé et le lb on voit la
bassée en clair simple et précis donc
non ensuite attardé un stade et on suit
donc c'est pas par de la tva ou de la
csg
maintenant il ya un problème non mais
moi je vous lis pour financer ces
nouvelles mesures
je veux dire si un sommet avec des plans
sans qu'on annonce le financement des
mesures personne ne le croit dernier
point majeur le financement de
l'activité partielle la france ne sait
pas gérer le temps d'activité partielle
les allemands en période de crise en
2009 avec 600 mille six cent mille
entreprises qui utilisait le temps
partiel il faut donc là aussi un
financement seller de ressources que je
vous dis par ailleurs après donc moi je
ne veux pas que csg ou tva puis sinon
c'est ça qu'il faut une ressource à moi
je vous interroger sur le coût du
travail
j'y viens et en terminant avec ça j'y
viens mon sentiment très très clair
c'est que c'est pas le sujet principal
vraiment je pense c'est les sujets que
je vous indique je rappelle qu'avec le
même coût du travail
navré de vous le dire je suis arrivé à
10,2 j'ai rendu la copie deux ans après
à 7 7 7 7 step un prof de coût du
travail
maintenant le président le gouvernement
dise attention là on a une accélération
des délocalisations
faut-il ou pas modifié le coût du
travail
moi j'y suis favorable sur à sa longue
de flux assez réservé sur la tva au tous
des cas si ça doit être fait oui ça doit
être petit voilà ça doit être fait et
aller au bout de 20 % dans les autres
et d'échouer à paimpol des choix un peu
plus pas plus parce que ça pèserait
évidemment sur les ménages et salvateur
ya aucun effet sur le pouvoir d'achat
jusqu'à et demi jusqu'à une minute
cazilhac aucun effet au delà il ya un
énorme effet voilà très bien voilà qui
éclaire juste un petit mot vous
confirmez vous avez mené une mission de
dialogue non avec les syndicats n'ont
cherché non non non rien du tout alors
tous les mois vous et ils n'ont pas
besoin de moi pour se pâmer nonce à
manger dit aux à résoudre ce que je
pense c'est ce qu'a déclaré fabien rage
alors jean louis borloo bon voilà qui
est clair
pour cette première partie vous abordez
volontiers aujourd'hui votre ambition
pour les élections législatives - votre
objectif pour la présidentielle vous
allez devoir néanmoins répondre à samir
tounsi de l'ahp juste après cette
enquête de paul bouffard donc sur votre
rêve aujourd'hui proclamé jean louis
borloo
j'ai roulé le rêve c'est ce que je sais
c'est que ma femme car la femme la plus
heureuse du monde
on essaye au passage votre rêve
constitué néanmoins en politique un
groupe charnière à l'assemblée nationale
pour peser paul bouffard à chacun sa
course il a dit non au sprint vers
l'elysée jean-louis borloo préfère une
course de fond celle des législatives
le député et le dit ouvertement devant
les micros sa nouvelle ambition
constituer un groupe charnière à
l'assemblée autour des radicaux
indépendant et centriste un
positionnement vitale pour les proches
de l'ancien ministre
il est nécessaire d'avoir un pôle
central qui soient forts pour justement
éviter les excès de parts et l'eau le
président du parti radical veut être
capable de peser sur les débats au
nouveau centre on grince des dents que
ce projet ne doit pas être la croisade
d'un seul homme il faut pas
personnaliser les choses parce que la
personnalisation celle d'élections
présidentielles et quand on est à
l'élection législative est un projet
collectif trente quarante cinquante
députés
à l'ump le nombre de postes semble
énorme surtout s'il n'ya pas soutien à
nicolas sarkozy
j'imagine que s'il veut un groupe de 50
ce sont des gens qui auraient
l'investiture de l'ump
je n'imagine pas des dizaines et des
dizaines de candidats radicaux élus
contre des candidats ump
si il ya un débat sur les investitures
ça
sens que j'ai naturellement l'ensemble a
soutenu le même candidat aux
présidentielles dans la majorité
présidentielle
on jette un oeil presque bienveillant
sur cette idée qui naîtrait grâce à
l'ump mais on aimerait surtout entendre
tout de suite jean louis borloo annoncé
qu'il votera nicolas sarkozy à la
présidentielle
voilà samir tounsi de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire pour ce
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 est avec
nous au grand soir samir un bon soir
michel aux questions à notre invité
bonsoir monsieur borloo alors répondez
nous annoncer le nous il y à des
négociations avec l'ump sur les
circonscriptions entre le parti radical
et l'ump
mais c'est tellement simple est ce que
l'ump m a accordée à contre moi à
valenciennes si je suis candidat il y
avoue nomen la réponse et vous je peux
vous dire c'est peu probable
voilà mais avec qui ce match allait
attendre ainsi permettre un candidat
contre jean grenet à bayonne ça serait
maladroit si le mp veut perdre toutes
les circonscriptions qui sont les nôtres
qui se dérange pas enfin la même chose
donc évidemment que ça marche pas comme
ça
nous on n'est pas comme entre le ps et
les verts en train de dire écoute on
sait pas bien tu as mangé pas une fille
elle est d'ailleurs très bien produit
vers cité à lille jamais vu passer votre
celi l écolo donc elle à la circo très
bien mais ça ne suffit pas à couvrir les
autres il n'y a pas de mondiaux alors il
ya il se trouve que nous avons des
candidats bien meilleur que celui un peu
d'ensemble de circonscription ce qui
s'est traduit en droit dévissé voyez
rama yade h liman par exemple ça va être
un petit endroit est américain avait
fixé la jauge de votre groupe charnière
à 30 50 députés
ouais je vois ses pouvoirs sur des
candidats ump dans ton est à 52 ans
battre à des candidats pécan ce camp
c'est pas décédé pas bon et nous quand
on a des pas bon on en mettra pas contre
eux voilà ça s'appelle des coalitions
ouais c'est assez classique quand tu es
dans une coalition êtes pas obligés de
faire des trucs idiots à la cliente à
négociation vous comptez y a pas de bras
mais on prend à chaque fois le meilleur
il se trouve qu'on a entre 35 et 50
meilleurs voilà mais dont vous arriver à
constituer ce groupe charnière on est
vraiment il ya beaucoup d'hypothèses il
faut que nicolas sark
eux que l'ump gagne l'élection qu'un
ancien lavoir qui rien à voir sans rien
à voir la charnière mais ça serait un
groupe explosion de cas de figure alors
oui il ya de toute façon des
législatives
ça n'aurait pas échappé je veux dire il
se trouve qu'il ya des présidentielles
puis après il existe et est ce que vous
pourrez entendre la vérité de gauche à
l'assemblée nationale sera un groupe qui
défendra samedi les militants des
groupes charnières ça veut dire nous
notre f&c que personne ne puisse
fonctionner sans nous 50 de butane même
là lâche mais dans tous les cas de
figure personne ne peut fonctionner sans
doute on va peut-être pas y arriver mais
ma conviction c'est que avoir des
systèmes complètement monolithique fait
que on zappe les pouvoirs
d'accompagnement les débats les
contre-pouvoirs les encadrements voilà
ce que je crois sous la vème lui ça a
toujours été comme ça j'ai le sentiment
que cette fois ci ça peut être différent
voilà peut-être que ça sera pas le cas
mais c'est en tous les cas clairement
notre ambition savez il ya deux façons
de faire peser un contre-pouvoir aux
grandes machines du siècle dernier qui
sont très pertinentes au siècle actuel
le ps et l'ump il ya dire je vais à la
présidentielle et puis je fais troisième
quatrième reine d'un soir puis lendemain
il se passe rien tu as toujours les deux
où tu décides d'avoir ou parlement le
groupe charnière c'est ce de façon
différente république
vous avez dit vous avez dit lors de
cette déclaration il ne faut pas
surprendre et l'élection
conscient des réactions de cette ville
ancienne ça veut dire que vous rejoignez
jean luc mélenchon et arnaud montebourg
en prêt doit lancer dans pour une
sixième république parlementaire et je
suis pas là pour commenter les autres je
vous dis une chose je vous en mets sur
votre opposition non mais vous me
demandez de commenter les propos de gens
que j'ai pas entendu dénis l'ubs
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que nous
avons une tendance en france mais tous
d'abord à croire qu'on un état central
ronald pies émietté deuxièmement comme
une espèce de monarchie les conférences
de presse du président qu est la seule
élection simple leur présidentielle la
présidente influencera la législative
elle influencera mais la vraie élection
action publique c'est là législatives
parce que c'est de là que sortira le
gouvernement de la france
on a vu un pays gouverné cinq ans par
lionel jospin sans que le président soit
de son camp on n'a jamais vu l' inverse
donc la présidentielle mais ça c'est
notre culture d'ailleurs on est regardée
dans le monde entier comme des êtres
aimés mais j'y suis je
j'en fais partie de cette culture ça
j'adore ce combat présidence est là mais
la vérité monsieur sait qu'elle va
influencer la législative elle ne sera
pas la clé des cinq années à venir
alors vous voulez occupé en quelque
sorte la position du centre donc un oui
mais le centre gouvernemental et
parlementaire pour la présidentielle il
y a un candidat eh oui le sait très bien
d'ailleurs
moi j'ai toujours dit que je ne voulais
pas être faire ce que nos combats du
centre où on aurait 18% ce partage est
de ça rime à quoi vous vous allez
choisir comme lui un ralliement à gauche
ou à droite en fonction comme quoi vous
êtes tous m'ont aidée par la seule
présidentielle alors que je vous dis que
l'élection importante c'est celle
d'après ouais c'est celle d'après
écoutez ce que je lis end à moi j'ai
bien entendu donc pour celle d'après
nous on va faire les conditions d'une
coalition coalition
cette coalition avec l'ump elle date
année il ya forcément avec lui un allié
de j'allais dire de deux premières
offres
même s'ils disent choqués que plus tôt
nous allier du mp une offre de deuxième
mais mais mais mais mais si on se met
pas d'accord mais ses méthodes et
excusez moi si on se met pas d'accord je
n'ai rien sur le sujet alors je
t'échange pas des cirques ou contre des
centrales ça marche pas comme ça on
n'est pas dans le caprice ça marche pas
comme ça
alors moi je souhaite une
proportionnelle en partie voter avant
d'accord pas une conversation voter
avant avant 2012
j'ai bon espoir que nous espérons si
vous connaissez mieux que nous les
contraintes du calendrier législatif
tellement que je les connais
parfaitement bien j'ai regardé ça très
attentivement ya un certain nombre de
capes trio c'est possible je vous donne
un autre exemple en omettant d'indiquer
saison la fiscalité est ce que vous
connaissez la plus grande injustice de
notre pays la plus grande c'est la
fiscalité locale selon que vous êtes
dans une île pauvre ou dans une huile
riche vous paierez dix fois plus
d'impôts dans une ville pauvre alors
qu'en général vous êtes vous vous même
pauvre et qu'on a besoin de services
publics que dans une ville riche c'est
de 1 à 13 cette affaire est un
vraisemblablement scandaleux moi je veux
un référendum sur la justice fiscale
locale
par ailleurs je souhaite qu'il y ait
l'égalité entre la fiscalité du travail
la fiscalité de capital
voilà c'est 15 le jury comme la gauche
mais mais mais je me fous des autres je
vous dise tradition non mais attendez
donc je vous ai dit on à une discussion
avec les heures et puis et puis on verra
nous avons des alliés naturels ou propre
des coalitions c'est d'avoir des années
là mais ça parle d'avoir des alliés
automatique parce que c'est pas une
coalition à ce moment là donc il va
falloir que chacun fasse un effort de
rapprochement
on verra surtout enfin si c'est un petit
peu parce que c'est important on verra
surtout qui va gagner l'élection
présidentielle et l'élection législative
attaque sans régime
je sus que nous sommes des produits de
la vème république assez cher auteur sa
mort ou double nous sommes pas encore en
allemagne dans des démocraties
parlementaires est ce que vous allez
vous faire connaître votre choix pour la
présidentielle mais symbole d'accord ou
pas de coalition
mettant des d'abord les français n'ont
pas besoin de moi pour faire leur choix
deuxièmement je suis contre a rien je
suis candidat à rien voilà c'est fait
neuf ans gouvernement je pense que j'ai
bien servi mon pays
là encore parler d'eux mais d'autres non
mais donc donc voila moi je donc on peut
très bien se passer de mon avis très
bien se passer
en calédonie moi je ne donnerai mon avis
qu si je suis convaincu dans le cadre
d'un accord de coalition voilà c'est
donc à quel moment il sera capable 1 405
a tardé à le faire et on l'a quand même
les gens inhumer dignement
je voulais dit comment il est grand
temps non mais il est laissé faire on en
train de terminer nous nos engagements
de circonscription
là je suis entend terminer ce soir nos
différents candidats
ça se passe plutôt pas mal y aura pas de
drame sûrs à quelques endroits un peu un
peu chaude et très bien on assemble
d'indépendants on a un certain nombre de
centristes de l'ump de culture démocrate
chrétienne qui ont envie de venir dans
cette dans cette alliance et on verra
c'est tout ça ça fait la maille vous
aurez des en-avants les 577 anciens
parce que ça c'est pas une condition ça
ça s'appelle d'une baston non mais tu
comprenais rien si vous mettez des
cordes y assister mais tribord coallier
c'est plus des alliés voilà donc un
allié si vous êtes d'accord dans la
sambre d'endroits où prenez les
meilleurs il ya quelques endroits où il
ya peu de cas style voilà ce qu'on nous
écoute c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours
un on ne sait pas toujours facile à
saisir les cdc en tant que ça sur moi la
cia cia jeunes téléspectateurs et lcp
qui revenait c'était les spectacles
huila contraire avait quand même quand
vous écoutez je me dis que vous ne
pouvez être avec vos députés qu'une
force d'appoint au sarkozysme demain
vous qui avez cessé de vouloir incarner
une alternative en vous présentant pas
mais vous êtes formidables merci mais
plus que ça d'ailleurs
l'action publique c'est servir les gens
est votre seule question c'est d'abord
est ce que vous avez envie de le faire
au détriment d'autres réactions
et si vous avez envie de vous y coller
encore un petit un petit peu ou faites
pas seul et vous dit comment je le sers
le mieux il se trouve que moi j'ai des
positions sur les banlieues sur le
logement social sur la fiscalité sur
l'industrie sur l'école notamment la
petite en france sur les dyslexiques sur
les lises hyperactif bon c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
aurais je m'en fous très franchement
carrière les derrière ça m'est
complètement égal
moi je suis là je préfère mon pays à un
clan ou un camp voilà donc je serai
parfaitement gratuitement engagé sans
rien demander
sur un programme qui me paraissent
confiants je vous donne un exemple j'ai
été heureux de dire à tout le monde ce
que je pensais de ce que devait devait
devenir ce sommet social emploi et paas
mais qui tourne exclusivement autour de
la tva
je pense qu'on passe à côté d'une très
grande partie du sujet immédiat des
demandeurs d'emploi la qualification
professionnelle la qualification des
adultes de logements sera pas là donc je
donne mon sentiment
et puis on verra ça mieux pour la
dernière question peut-être les arrivées
de philippe douste blazy pour rejoindre
françois bayrou il dénonce une
droitisation de l'ump vous pourriez les
reprendre à votre compte
mais tout ça c'était phrase moi j'adore
politique c'est une âme et oui mais non
mais non non non je suis désolé moi ce
qui m'agace c'est les programmes il ya
des progrès opérationnels exhorte
rentrer dans des renards de forme
d'impasse indiqué louis c'est pour ça
que le rapport de force politique
je vous le dis pour quelqu'un qui n'est
pas vraiment totalement à droite et pas
franchement socialiste vous avez deux
conceptions la consoeur monarchie
consiste à aller à la présidentielle
mais le soir quand vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas un ou deux
le troisième quel que soit son score
c'est juste un battus du premier tour et
vous ne peser rien parce que c'est pas
vrai que c'est sur un coin de table
contre deux tours entre le mercredi et
le jeudi
vous imposer un programme de
gouvernement en revanche maintenant on
peut le faire
vous voulez changer de république jamais
pas du tout je veux pas chagrin plus je
voudrais qu'on mette en place les
programmes que je souhaite sur
l'industrie sur les prêts participatifs
pour les pour les pme fin élite écrit un
livre assez nom sur tous ces sujets là
je crois dans ce que je dis que c'est
terrible donc j'essaie de trouver le
moins mauvais moyen pour signer parvenir
c'est simple est ce que vous êtes séduit
ce sera peut-être la dernière question
donc purement politique un par la
démarche
de françois bayrou qui s'enrichit bien
qu'on soit tous qu'il n'est pas en train
de réaliser ce que vous nous exploser
aujourd'hui mettant des je pense que si
françois n'a pas un groupe politique à
l'assemblée
même si il était au deuxième tour ça
revient ce qui est le lendemain un
affrontement ps l'ump et ça sera un
grand président mais le sujet politique
il est six semaines plus tard vous
attendez attendez
et si les troisièmes ou quatrièmes ça ne
pèse pas ce n'est pas vrai voilà ce qui
pèse ça influencera d'élections mais ça
ne posera pas françois est quelqu'un que
je connais par coeur
j'étais son porte parole j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour lui donc c'est pas du tout
ils sont plein de sujets on a des
sensations des sentiments des
impressions un regard lui entoure 8000
tonnes mais mais la question c'est après
après mésentente avec votre qu'est ce
qu'on fait c'est pas arrivé l'an passé
le sujet le plus important quel que soit
l'élu c'est important cette année j'ai
bien compris il vous dit françois bayrou
peut avoir des chances et vous vous êtes
là derrière avec le groupe pop a ha il
est très fort il est trop fort qu'elle
gymnastes famille avec dernière question
vous allez dire vous allez nous accabler
de mes genoux accablement tous les noms
d'oiseaux politico journalistique du
monde mais la question va se poser
nicolas sarkozy ou françois bayrou vous
allez être appelé à soutenir des deux
candidats marcheuses et dia quart
d'heure où il ya dix minutes quand on a
commencé que ça serait un accord de
coalition l'accord de coalition par
nature il se construit il se bâtit sur
des valeurs et sur des programmes voilà
et deuxièmement moi je veux un accord de
coalition avec des gens qui sont en
situation d'avoir des troupes au
parlement parce qu'une fois de plus
monsieur juste pas gouverner la france
sans que la gauche ou à l'elysée le
pouvoir aux france il est issu du
parlement qui désigne le gouvernement
qui vient demander la question de
confiance
évidemment que la présidentielle qui est
l'élection de coeur des français qui
l'élection d'émotion des français
quel moment où il essaie d'exprimer des
valeurs influencera la législative mais
là elle ne décidera pas à la place de la
génétique très bien voilà merci seigneur
on va revenir avec perrine tarneaud dans
un instant sur vos motivations jean
louis borloo qui sont moins incertaine
pour nous un espace à mur après ce quart
d'heure est également et surtout
peut-être sur votre renoncement à la
présidentielle qui reste pour beaucoup
mystérieux comment vos fidèles la navy
stylet vous justin jean louis borloo
avec le recul de quelques mois
maintenant
reportage signé aïda qui recrache j'en
ai dans l'eau j'ai mis ce monde de
course 2 octobre 2011 à celle à être
dans la confidence
rama yade a prévenu dix minutes avant
l'annoncé du scoop un privilège
tous ont été fauchés par le renoncement
de leurs leaders
un mélange de tristesse parce que je
considère que jean louis est quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup beaucoup de qualités pour
exercer de hautes responsabilités je
crois que c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable d'apporter sa contribution dans
le débat présidentiel sans pour autant
être candidat d'autres l'avaient senti
venir
j'ai senti à deux universités d'été de
la grande motte j'avais été
l'organisateur son son malaise
persistant peut-être qu'il n'avait pas
en lui-même la force pour surmonter des
obstacles que son intelligence percevait
jean louis borloo garder son image
d'électron libre
gérard larcher qui lui doit ses
meilleurs souvenirs ministériel quand il
fonctionner en tandem se montre le plus
bienveillant brouillon peut-être mais il
est comme ça on trois ans ministère nous
avons vécu comme ça direct spontané
naturel avec que ça pouvait parfois
avoir de désarçonnant dont certains
c'est vrai qu'il n'est pas dans le
modèle habituel et et il a une forme de
parler qui est authentique et sincère en
tout les cas je le ressens comme ça
c'est la nature de nos échanges tous les
deux et pourquoi donc lâché gg j'ai une
profonde amitié pour jean louis borloo
marginalisés pour beaucoup ils ont louis
borloo peut encore compter sur des
fidèles ceux qui ont déjà pardonné à la
perrine tarneaud nous force à mon sens
jean louis borloo on le voit dans ce
sujet vos troupes elles se remettent un
peu doucement elles ont eu le sentiment
d'être un peu abandonné trahi
est ce que vous aviez sous-estimé la
déception de ceux qui vous suivent vous
rendez compte le film que temps de
pardonner je suis quand même tous les
hommes politiques veulent être candidats
à la présidentielle pratiquement tous
alors voilà un individu qui est entre 8
et 11% dans les sondages qui fait
l'analyse politique qu'il faut pas le
faire c'est lui le coupable mais tandis
que vous attendez pas été déçus qu'il
existe mais trahie de parrainer donné
l'occasion de m'exprimer je le faire
comme vous êtes tous formatés sur la
monarchie présidentielle et que
évidemment un homme politique il en
rigolant mais parle de matadi d'être
candidat de parti
ridha les caméras mais attendez quand
vous êtes à 4% à 5% vous pensez rien du
tout vous avez envie d'aller devant les
caméras voilà bon pas tous mais c'est
quand même et vous vous pouvez pas
concevoir qu'un homme politique fasse
l'analyse suivante dans la crise que
nous traversons madame la crise que nous
traversons il va y avoir deux candidats
l'alternance bien organisée avec un type
de grande qualité et à présent sortons
et parce que madame le pen au printemps
à jouer l'euro l'europe les frontières
le drame industrielle elle devient chef
des souverainistes et qu'en réalité le
mag qui va jouer à trois et ce qui peut
leur est ce qu'on appelle le centre les
modérés les républicains les radicaux
des démocrates-chrétiens une bataille de
deux individus là n'avaient strictement
aucun sens je maintiens cette analyse
politique évidemment com - shell 1 sp
tic qu'à l'époque j'ai annoncé devant
vos confrères 1 que monsieur papandreou
quitterait la scène politique par
l'armée grecque ou par des
manifestations ou devant sein de son
propre que monsieur berlusconi ne
passerait pas l'hiver
j'ai annoncé qu'il y avait un risque
majeur pour la dégradation de la france
à l'époque en août et en septembre
j'ai pris mes responsabilités attendait
et jeudi il est pas raisonnable d'aller
dans cette élection présidentielle je
pense que c'est par les législatives et
les concepts qu'on pèse peut-être que je
me trompe je prends mes responsabilités
et c'est vrai que le petit jeu
médiatique consiste à dire 'attendez
s'il va pas mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire mais il a ce sont les explications
de politique il ya forcément derrière
des motivations aussi personnel
annoncées celle que je vous dis j'ai
fait madame une analyse politique
cette analyse politique lisez mon livre
que j'écris en juillet août
lisez les quatre premières pages dans
lequel ans je vous explique noir sur
blanc ce que je pense et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je serai quelqu'un de pas
responsable en étant candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avec un poteau
électrique qui à l'époque était le
double de françois bayrou on aura une
espèce d'affrontements qui a dit il
du mans tout et qui de surcroît
risquerait de fausser ce débat là pour
ça que françois face face et moi je
m'occupe des législatives mais c'est
très important parce que on peut pas en
permanence expliqué que les hommes
politiques veulent raconter être
candidat à tout et quand il y en a un
qui dit attendez j'ai réfléchi je pense
que c'est par exemple
oulala ça ça cache quelque chose et
penser en plus qu'il faut qu'il se fasse
pardonner que vont proposer son destin
personnel qu'il faut avoir envie d'y
aller
il faut avoir cette motivation ce moteur
personnel oui bah écoutez ça suffit pas
voilà qu'en avocat paris avec 150
collaborateurs
j'avais pas père avocat pas de mère
avocate pas de magistrat
c'était mon bébé je décide d'aller à
valenciennes et je me rends compte au
bout de six mois je peux pas faire les
deux jeux qui tous et que je passe douze
ans de ma vie
excusez moi ça c'est un engagement mois
le prix de l'engagement je sais ce que
c'est il faut plus de courage pour aller
à 20 heures pour dire voilà je ne crois
pas que ça soit responsable que de faire
l' inverse
voilà ce que je crois personnellement et
je sais bien savais le rôle d'un chef
c'est abandonner de dire à
contre-courant tout le monde
ce qu'ils croient être bien pour sa
famille pour son pays voilà alors je
sais que ça pas été compris c'est
possible mais c'est extravagant c'est
extravagant parler d'affaires oui c'est
ça mais qui paraît un peu jean marie
bockel la l'instant il dit il n'avait
peut-être pas en lui la force suffisante
pour surmonter les obstacles et la bête
ancien mari me nommer jean marais mais
qu'il le pense c'est son droit le plus
strict j'observe aujourd'hui d'abord que
moi je suis en pleine forme je suis
heureux de vous voir
je suis heureux de dire ce que j'ai à
dire sur sable et social et le reste et
je veux même élite tout ça mais détendue
avec une capacité de continuer à voyager
à réfléchir rencontrer des gens aient de
manière totalement libre petit libre
engagé
donc je serai en campagne mais je serai
toujours en train d'essayer de monter
des coups des pilotes des matches à
attendait mais pas la regarder sonde à
l'heure où il avait failli dire ma
carrière est derrière lui elle est
derrière vous mais dans les cas où et
quand j'avais été non mais quand vous
avez été combien je suis plus même
grosse grosse décennie député nancy
régional des notaires temps des nouveaux
ministres numéro 2 ou en guise d taton
est votre problème c'est comment je gère
mon pays mais s'il faut que ce soit par
une ong
si c'est papin ont proprement ou en
montant un organe de presse pour peser
ça m'est égal ce que je veux moi je veux
dire mais il ya quand même une politique
et je veux défendre mes idées
loool moyens c'est pas toujours la
candidature mais ce que vous avez eu des
doutes au point de totalement raccrocher
en politique de ça dépend ce que vous a
plu raccrocher c'était vraiment finir
avec la politique et à mai avec
l'anglais mais moi j'adore ça
vous êtes hors sables maison mais payés
par exemple les législatives à
valenciennes j'ai dit à tout le monde la
gl les enfants ça fait 20 ans que je me
suis dit que j'y suis avec cécilia l'est
qui en fait a fait de la députée soyez
gentil
allez on va pas toujours appelé les
mêmes équipes
donc si on peut trouver une nouvelle
équipe si génial je l'aiderai si on n'a
pas d'autre ce compte là c'est simple
avis madame à gg quand vous changez donc
vous avez des façons différentes
d'exercer votre métier ou vos
convictions
voilà moi sonné je sais plus dans le
champ ministériel pure mais vous avez
toujours construire votre carrière sur
des aventures passionné est ce qui a
encore besoin de lui des buts des
objectifs en dehors de la politique vous
inspirer de nouvelles garanties rabat
par exemple parlement et par exemple
contribué à avoir des fonds publics pour
industrialiser notre pays pas vraiment
au gouvernement moi je suis fasciné par
les cinq six gamins par classe dont on
sait la maîtresse y a pas que toute
façon qu'ils sont hors normes
comment légère avec qui je suis fascinée
pour terminer ce plan rénovation urbaine
des banlieues françaises 43 milliards
can change harry tu voudrais qu'on
termine
partie emploi c'est les choses qui me
passionnent à d'autres qui me passionne
vous savez quels sont les deux seuls
eldorado français détendent temps qui
viennent c'est la mer et des océans et
c'est l'afrique voilà les 12 univers
dans lesquels notre pays un avenir
d'emploi technologique de ressources
c'est la richesse dans la mer et des
océans et c'est cette extraordinaire
continent qu'est l'afrique voilà des
sujets qui me passionnent
beaucoup de sujets vous est ouvert à
tous mais plus candidat à rien exact on
a résumé baisse avant dernière à
journalisme et sur soie vous remplacer
dans sa peine et me choper influence la
vie politique c'est un dernier mot sur
rama yade qui a été rayé des listes
électorales à colombes est ce que c'est
l'imprudence de sa part
c'est un acharnement contre elle a coûté
honnêtement je connais pas le sujet tout
ce que je sais c'est que je la
connaissais
non mais attendez il ya une chose que je
peux vous dire c'est que je la
soutiendrai à mort
voilà pas bien merci pour elle une
petite question encore on a appris au
cours de l'émission que l' agence de
notation standard and poor ce contre
laquelle vous avez décidé de partir bien
l'action en justice a dégradé une bonne
petite action responsable et en résulte
alors à succès nous passions du genre
elle a décidé aussi de dégrader les
notes de la cadc de l'unedic mais non
mais c'est automatique automatiquement
cette somme à autre chose lors de vos
voeux vous avez répété que vous
attendiez de françois fillon on connaît
vos relations avec le montrer les
décrets d'application gijon les fameux
maghrébins d'origine
donc le jury étrangères pour l'essentiel
algérien ennuyons les françaises
ils sont venus en france cette histoire
mais ce que françois fillon vous adonner
à des mains parce que voter est acteurs
connaissent pas ils sont venus en france
pour calais et voulait repartir chez eux
ils n'ont pas demandé le regroupement
familial
ils peuvent pas rentrer chez eux pour
des raisons de bon j'avais fait voter
noah et son dordé sonacotra ils sont 30
mais franchement vous attendez des
classes n'a pas répondu le premier
ministre a encore mais ils me disent de
l'intérieur m'a dit que c'était une
bonne idée qui s'en occupait merci à
rooney tard que samedi
merci pour toutes ces informations
communiquées aujourd'hui lors de cette
émission jean louis borloo notamment
votre combat judiciaire la semaine
prochaine luc chatel le ministre de
l'éducation nationale sera notre invité
bonsoir à tous